all right we are now about to have
another live reading from my book uh
reason fulfilled by revelation the 1930s
christian philosophy
debates in france and we're getting
close to the end of these we have two
more
sessions after
this one today we are going to be
reading a
fairly lengthy piece by at that time the
young fernan von steinbergen
uh entitled the society tomi's second
day of studies and the notion of
christian philosophy
and this was published in the review neo
scholastic de philosophy
uh
in 1933 and volume 35. the other two
remaining pieces from the book were also
interestingly enough published in
review
neo-scholastic philosophy which was um
you know becoming an important venue for
these discussions
by um the you know the middle point of
the debates 1933 we're talking about the
debates having been going on for
about two years and they would go on for
another two years after that so this is
a very important document
and i i do want to say this
before we get started so this reference
to the society told me second day of
studies what does that mean so the
society tom east was a relatively new
organization at least in terms of
holding sessions and it was
you could say it was it was francophone
in the sense that the discussions were
carried out but it included an
international
audience so
um you know germans and italians and
belgians not just not just french
and um the first day of studies was
devoted to tomism and phenomenology
edith stein was the guest of honor there
the second
year
they decided to focus on this question
of christian philosophy and now this
this is not a document the the accounts
of the discussions has not been
translated yet but i hope to do that
perhaps someday in the future all right
so
all that said
let's jump into the reading and then
after i read through these 15 pages
we should hopefully still have some time
for q a
and discussion
we remember the success that crowned the
initiative last year of the organizers
of the society tommy's first day of
studies held at
on september 12 1932 and devoted to the
subject of phenomenology the second day
of studies on 11 september this year
attracted an equally numerous group of
philosophers historians and theologians
come from france italy england austria
and belgium
among the persons present let us note
the dominican orders many illustrious
representatives the reverend father
mondonet the reverend father certian and
the reverend father chanu president of
the associate home east the french
university was represented by mr jill
song professor at the college of france
by mr guilier professor at lille and by
mr foret professor at poitiers
monsieur bruno de solage director of the
catholic institute of toulouse presided
over the morning session
the catholic institute of paris sent as
delegate the abe raoul cartoon and the
catholic institute of leon the abe
reggie olivet
among the foreign members let us mention
monsignor monsavo from the university of
the sacred heart at milan dom foiling
always order of saint benedict from the
university of salzburg the reverend
father mark society jesus from the
jersey house of study the abe penito
from the university of freiburg in
switzerland and finally monsignor noel
and mr mason from the university of
leuven
the very cordial welcome the organizers
prepared for their guests assured a
character of delicious simplicity and an
almost familial atmosphere for the
meeting
waiting on publication of the official
accounts of the juvici meeting sessions
our readers would like to know the broad
outlines of the debates after giving a
brief account i will try to determine
the conclusions that in my view can be
drawn from the 11 september discussions
an allocution by the reverend father
chanu well wishes and an introduction of
the subject opened the day then we heard
mr amy forex report on the historical
problem of christian philosophy
foreign started from a christian
philosophy as a fact as something given
quote history encounters a certain
number of doctrines that present
themselves as christian philosophies the
problem that is raised then is this one
do they merit this title thanks to the
union between reason and faith
established in them
having no other task than introducing
the debate mr ferret confined himself to
recalling the attitudes that have been
adopted in the course of history and he
reduced the interpretations of the
relation between reason and faith to
three essential types separation
reduction of faith to reason and union
developing this last position he
developed two typical attitudes that of
mr mariten and that of mr blondel
let us recall his report's conclusion
historical study would show us therefore
at what moment in the diverse doctrines
the theoretical difficulty they always
encounter is situated
and would aid us in understanding how
reason and faith can be an agreement
solely in the attitude of a christian
philosophy
after a speech by the reverend father
festuhir trying to establish the
doctrinal influence of christianity
through the concrete example of the
notion of personality the reverend
father chanu gave the floor to mr jill
song who imparted some very valuable
confidences to the assembly relative to
the position he took on the debate on
christian philosophy
mr joseon declared himself convinced of
the deep and decisive influence that
christianity has exercised on the
evolution of western thought
it is that influence that he wanted to
shed light on and it is the fruit of
that influence that he wished to
characterize by the expression christian
philosophy
but he does not at all cling to that
expression in preference to any other
and he does not claim that it would be
exempt from inconveniences and he
declared himself ready to renounce it
then and there if necessary
all the same he remained persuaded of
the real difference that exists between
the methods of theology and of christian
philosophy such as he has defined them
in his works
the reverend father mondonet intervened
then in very categorical and insistent
terms to contend against this expression
christian philosophy
at certain moments the eminent historian
seemed to deny any doctrinal influence
of christian revelation in the working
out of medieval philosophies and he
seemed to attribute tomism superiority
over aristotelianism exclusively to
saint thomas's philosophical genius
but what followed this discussion shows
that the reverend father mondanet wished
to forcefully highlight the necessary
autonomy of philosophical inquiry
responding to a question by monsieur
bruno de salaj mr gilson affirmed that
in his view christian philosophy's
doctrinal influence is not entirely
assimilable to the influence that a
person of genius can exercise on the
intellectual development of humanity it
seems that we find ourselves there in
the presence of a specifically different
factor
the afternoon session opened with the
report by the reverend father mott
order of preachers towards a doctrinal
solution of the problem of christian
philosophy
how
do the historically observed relations
between christian faith and
philosophical thought justify themselves
doctrinally
the real in its integrity is one but for
man there are two modes of knowledge
rational knowledge and the knowledge of
faith
there is thus room for a double vision
of the universe a vision of reason and a
vision of faith partial and
complementary truths which cannot
contradict each other
but among the different branches of
rational knowledge what is particular to
metaphysics is that its object being qua
being
coincides with the integral real and
cannot accept any limitation
on the other hand while unlimited as to
its object metaphysics is imperfect and
limited as to the way in which it
narrows down this object
which infinitely exceeds the proper
object of human knowledge
quote opening toward all being and
adequation toward to the integral real
such are philosophical reasons aspects
that will determine its attitude in
relation to faith
one capable by its universality and its
flexibility of supporting revelations
divine contribution it will place itself
at the service of faith to help it
penetrate the revealed datum's
intelligibility one will then end up in
theological science by faith as a whole
dependent on the supernatural science of
god
two incapable of getting to the bottom
of its own object on its own it will
seek assistance through proximity to
revelation and if it does that without
introducing anything that would be
formally foreign to the rational order
we will have the philosophy that merits
the name
christian
this enrichment of philosophy by faith
results from doctrinally objective
contributions
and from subjective aids offered to
reason lastly let us cite the report's
conclusion
when one baptizes the philosophy
elaborated under this influence as
christian the epithet characterizes less
the work itself
which remains in its foctum essay
formally independent of faith than in
its fiery here christianity has played
an essential role
father mott's penetrating report soon
provoked a very lively exchange of views
which was put to an end only when the
hour for tea time and closure came
the reverend father certian proposed
distinguishing different possible
functions of christian philosophy and
strove in that way to reconcile the
positions of mr joseo mr blondel and
even mr gabriel marcel
certiance thought that a revealed truth
the mystery of incarnation for example
would be able to be the object of two
distinct speculations
that of the theologian and that of the
christian philosopher
a rather confused discussion ensued on
this point and the abe markar professor
of the seminary of rems fortunately put
an end to it by proposing to father
sertian that in one of his next studies
he showed by a concrete example
what in his view philosophical study on
the one hand and theological study on
the other of a supernaturally revealed
truth would consist
then don foyling read a communication
whose technical vocabulary was borrowed
from the phenomenological school and
which tried to establish that the
expression christian philosophy
could not have a rigorous meaning
the abe penito asked without getting an
exact response how a philosophy that
moves within the interior of a faith
could be distinguished from theology a
discussion was raised between monsignor
monsolvo and mr jill song monsignor
monsolva rejected any direct influence
on of faith in the very constitution of
philosophy
and called any philosophy christian that
remained open to christianity and to the
extrinsic compliments revelation
contributes to rational knowledge
in spite of these quite confused
discussions and divergences at first
glance considerable of ideas
the september 11th meeting seems to me
to have made evident a real agreement on
many important points if not among all
the participants at least for the
majority
in the first place it was agreed that
the christian teaching has exercised a
real and deep influence on the
historical evolution of western
philosophy saint thomas's or done
scotus's philosophy would not have
existed without the coming of
christianity and without the influence
of christian doctrine on the
intellectual life of christian thinkers
on this central point we can say that mr
brahier is not followed by any catholic
historian
in its turn
the historical fact of this influence
raises problems
that are as important as they are tricky
is the arrival of christianity as a
social institution and a doctrine the
natural result of pre-existing factors
or does it impose itself as a new fact
unexplainable by laws of historical
evolution and deriving from the
intervention of a transcendent cause
these problems need not keep us here
right now
second
it was agreed to declare that a
philosophy in the proper sense of the
term even if it is worked out on
christian ground and by the effort of a
christian thinker cannot speaking
formally bear the epithet christian
on this point again
the most formal declarations those of
father chanu and of father certian were
laid out at juvensi
without anyone raising the uh protest at
all speaking formally and with complete
rigor of the term there has not been
there cannot be christian philosophy
the noun and this adjective are
essentially ill-fitting and can only
more or less accidentally be assembled
together though than they can be with
truth
finally it was agreed to recognize that
in the mind of a christian the regime to
which faith and reason christian
doctrine and philosophy must be
submitted is not a regime of separation
nor a regime of pure and simple
subordination of reason to faith but a
regime of union and of reciprocal
relations
there even exists we believe a very
considerable unity of viewpoint on the
exact nature of these relations
in any case there is an ecclesiastic
teaching on these matters that can be
called traditional and that bears
particularly on the following points
the role of reason and preparation of
faith the methodological autonomy of the
sciences end of philosophy the moral
necessity of revelation the negative
control exercised by faith on the
conclusions of scientific research
the new psychological conditions created
by faith and by the christian life
notions and conceptions suggested by
revelation moral rectitude serenity in
the search for the true
the use of philosophy in the scientific
elaboration of the revealed datum that
is in theology in catholic circles these
things are known and taught going back a
long time now
and it does not seem that anyone in
these circles dreams of placing them
into doubt
but then is there room for a real
disagreement between partisans and
opponents of christian philosophy or are
we simply in the presence of one of
those quarrels of words as sterile as
they are unpleasant
precision and exactitude of language
have always been considered as
indispensable conditions for good
scientific work and we propose saint
thomas these days as an example when we
say about him with some exaggeration
however
semper formalism
i was also surprised to see especially
at juvensee that the best minds make
such an effort to maintain the
fashionableness and official recognition
of an expression whose lack of rigor
and improper character they proclaim at
the same time
when i chance to ask what the reasons
for this insistence were they answered
me that everyone was talking about
christian philosophy that it was
therefore a matter of a consecrated
expression and that all that remained
was its acceptable meaning
and here's a translator's note
von steinbergen's exact words were if we
are all in agreement that the expression
christian philosophy is lame i do not
understand why we are fighting to keep
it can we not find another expression
like christian wisdom the meaning that
this term covers is very confused that
is a sort of amalga amalgam of synthesis
the response he mentions is given to him
by sir tian chanu and mott
all right back to von steinberg's piece
i would place myself within this
conciliating group of serious
inconveniences were not the outcome but
from different sides a tendency is
displayed
of giving the expression in question a
true technical signification and making
christian philosophy a genre of
speculation intermediary between
philosophy to core and theology but in
the view of numerous and authoritative
persons whose opinion i merely represent
here this tendency rests on an inexact
conception of philosophy and theology
and it is the kind of thing that will
mix up things that are already only too
confused and it seems it must bring
consequences fatal to christian thoughts
development
must we enumerate several indices of
this tendency
to illuminate them it will be first
useful to recall and outline how the
different elements of knowledge must be
organized following a conception that
seemed common until these last years and
that seems to be in conformity both to
the nature of things and to the
traditional teaching
one philosophy is the scientific effort
that strives for a general explanation
of the real to the degree that it makes
the object of man's natural knowledge
philosophy's principles
methods and conclusions are therefore
strictly rational
two
it is possible legitimate and desirable
that christian thinkers strive to
establish a philosophy understood in
this sense it is possible
because every scientific work is a work
of critical and methodologic methodical
reflection but in reflection of this
kind the christian can quite well set
aside data to which he adheres by faith
just as he sets aside the opinions and
convictions of common sense so as to
stick only with data offered to natural
knowledge
it is legitimate for faith's constancy
does not in any way exclude
methodological doubt and critical
examination applied to any human
affirmation whatsoever and to the very
value of knowledge as such
it is desirable
for several reasons to start because
every truth even partial is a good for
man after that because on the ground of
philosophical research
an intellectual context is possible
between believers and unbelievers and
this contact is evidently a good since
it preserves the believers from
intellectual isolation and since it
opens to minds restless for religious
truth the normal way that should lead
them to faith finally the subtle work of
the theologian is possible only
to the degree
that a philosophy in the proper sense
as a preliminary and independent of any
theological preoccupation has been
established a philosophy capable of
supplying the rational instrument for
theological speculation
this we must say
is difficult work for it tries to
combine two categories of profoundly
disparate elements the revealed datum
received by faith and the rational datum
elaborated by philosophy
the synthesis of these two data has no
chance at all of being well favored if
one does not take care to study them
preliminarily on their own accounts in a
manner as to fix their contact their
contents exactly
three
in working out a philosophy in the
proper sense of the term christianity
never intervenes except in an indirect
and accidental manner
christianity's direct influence is of a
purely psychological order and confines
itself to putting christian philosophy
in the best conditions to work out not a
christian philosophy
this term lacking meaning but a true
philosophy
that revelation intervenes to suggest
some ideas to the christian philosopher
some insight some possibilities that he
would not have glimpsed without it that
it aids him to nuances a simplistic
conception that the christian life
ensures interior peace the love of truth
serenity and sincerity in the research
in all these cases
christianity does nothing except setting
up preliminary and extrinsic conditions
favorable to philosophical labor
once this work begins it is submitted to
its own laws to the exclusion of any
other in its fiery as in its foctum
essay philosophy is the work of reason
a christian's philosophy possesses
nothing specifically different from any
other philosophy faith does not put its
philosophy above the rational level any
more than it shelters it from error
four
philosophy being an effort of integral
explanation of the real it aims at
interpreting religious facts just as
much as any others
philosophy of religion will therefore be
numbered among general philosophies
branches of application just like
philosophy of science
uh philosophy of history philosophy of
civilization and the like
the philosophy of religion will permit
space for a philosophy of christianity
it will consistent studying
in the light of philosophical principles
christianity is a historical fact and as
a social reality
under this double aspect christianity in
fact forms part of the datum that offers
itself to man's natural knowledge
this study like other branches of
philosophical knowledge offers a
scientific interest but not a vital
interest to the christian since he is
informed elsewhere and from the best
source about christianity's
signification
it equally presents an apologetic
interest for it could be that it ends up
an affirmation of christianity's
transcendence and in this way opens the
path that leads to faith
it seems mr blondel's so fertile works
must be situated here to the extent they
claim to fall under philosophy and not
apologetics but for that philosophy to
merit the epithet of christian or
catholic
it does not suffice that a philosophy
explore
man's religious needs and recognize
philosophical explanations gaps in this
domain
or even that a call for man's wish is a
transnatural response to the aspirations
of the human soul
to the extent that it remains faithful
to its methods no philosophy can claim a
priori to empty out the real by giving
an exhaustive explanation of it
actually the real overflows the pure
rational at every point
every philosophy runs into multiple
mysteries and remains from that point on
open to a beyond of pure reason every
philosophy runs into the religious fact
in particular the christian fact and
this encounter provides a place for a
philosophy of christianity but one does
not call a philosophy of christianity
christian philosophy any more than one
calls a philosophy of civilization
civilized philosophy or a philosophy of
history historical philosophy
quote we ought then to observe that the
principal obstacle to faith among
philosophers taken as such is the
pretension to sufficiency and to suffice
onto themselves in so far
as they have not gotten out of that
pretension on their own grounds and by
their own methods ambiguities continue
the autonomy of thought a just claim in
itself from a general point of view
gladly sets itself up as an absolute
and it seems it has the right to do so
in so far as it has not been limited
philosophically
this is exactly what i maintain and it
is precisely because every sincere and
complete philosophy must itself finish
in a philosophy of insufficiency and
allow a philosophy of religion and a
philosophy of christianity that the
title christian must be rejected
it would come to qualify
one of the branches of philosophical
knowledge by its material object and
from that point on in a non-pertinent
manner
five
every scientific working out in which
the revealed datum formally intervenes
as a source of knowledge belongs by
definition to theology
theology distinguishes itself precisely
from all the properly human sciences by
the fact that it makes recourse to a
different light than that of reason
from that point on whether one starts
with revelation to explain it in reason
or whether one starts with reason in
order to illuminate it by revelation one
is always doing theology one does good
theology in the former case bad theology
in the latter case for in good method it
is revelation that is the principle of
theological knowledge
actually in any scientific
systematization the most certain and the
most fundamental truths must serve as
bases or principles but in theology
the revealed truths duly established and
made precise by positive theology are
clearly the most certain and most
fundamental
they must therefore constitute the
cornerstones
of the philosophical edifice
six so imagine an extra finger here
in theological knowledge defined in this
way there is room to distinguish
theology in the strict sense
and theology in the broad sense
in the strict and current sense of the
word theology is a systematic
organization of the content of
revelation made precise explained
developed by rational speculation
but always in the specific line of the
revealed
but beyond the theological synthesis one
can envision a totalization or synthesis
of all the human knowledge as a supreme
unification of all human knowing
whatever its origin may be
and sense in this ultimate synthesis the
dominant element in the principle of
order will necessarily be the revealed
atom it is a matter of a superior
theology of a theology in the broad
sense or if you like of the supreme
philosophical theological synthesis
the human mind strives towards unity but
this unity cannot be realized except by
the final organization of the different
degrees of knowing
just as a general philosophy is
completed by a philosophy of the
particular sciences so on a superior
plane theology must be brought to
fruition in an ultimate effort of
integration of all human knowledge
would one now like some concrete
examples of the tendency under the name
of christian philosophy to mix things up
important to carefully distinguish
i've recently brought up many of them
under the pen of mr gilson under father
romeyers and even under mr mara tens
father mondonet brought up the same
deficiency when he reproached mr jillson
with having laid out the thomas
philosophy along the plan of the somatia
logiai such a procedure can end up
laying out successive fragments of the
thomas philosophy but it cannot
establish that homoism
truly deserves the name philosophy
still how few expositions of tomism how
few manuals of thomas philosophy took
care to present tomism as a living
organism
that develops itself progressively
beginning from a critical point of
departure sheltered from any postulate
and any arbitrary affirmation
so far as one is not shown in st
thomas's work the at least virtual
presence of this type of synthesis
one has not established the existence of
atomist philosophy
what at the head of a manual of
philosophy does the title signify soma
philosophy christianity
shall it be that one defines there the
accident id
debit or essay
in such a way as to reserve for oneself
a convenient explanation of the dogma of
transubstantiation
or that one distinguishes there with the
same goal the extension of quantity will
it be that one defines the person there
in view of an easy interpretation of the
dogma of the hypostatic union
some professor of metaphysics treats the
divine attributes of unity truth
goodness with respect to the
corresponding transcendental properties
before having demonstrated the existence
of god and before having been able to
show after that the exact signification
of god's attributes an absence of care
for the philosophical interconnection of
problems
when mr farrett speaks of using faith in
the very constitution of philosophy or
when he thinks that reason and faith can
be reconciled solely in the attitude of
a christian philosophy
does he not confuse the personal
attitude of the christian philosopher
and the method of philosophy
and when father mott assures us that a
philosophy can be christian in its fiery
does he not confuse the psychological
coming to being of a science and it's
logical coming to being
christianity
can exercise a direct influence on the
mind of a philosopher
and from that point on modify the
psychological conditions of its labor
but in the articulation of philosophy
itself everything is reduced to the
objects that is the immediate atoms
being put to use by means of strictly
rational methods
once again christianity will be able to
contribute indirectly to making a true
philosophy be worked out by the
christian philosopher but not a
christian philosophy
in this respect let us take again an
example that was used at juvensi but for
a different end from the height of a
tower i overlook a vast landscape and i
barely distinguish far off imprecise
shapes
somebody passes me a commander's map
thanks to which i can easily recognize a
series of objects a village a church a
mill a footpath the map helps me to see
but will one say write off that i have
of the landscape the vision of a
commander or a vision of the commander's
map
i have quite simply a better natural
vision than before
and it goes the same for philosophy
faith teaches me that god is a creator
thanks to that suggestion i will be able
to more rapidly and more surely discover
the philosophical demonstration that
ends up in the causa ascendi universalis
has provided the occasion for a
philosophical progress
i raise again a last ambiguity in father
mott's contribution
it is the second attitude he attributes
to philosophical reason in relation to
faith it seems to me that philosophical
reason is perfectly capable of getting
by itself to the basis of its proper
object since the proper object is by
definition the object proportion to its
faculty of knowledge and if as i assume
one must not give here the word proper
its formal sense in other words if it is
a matter of the incapacity for the
intellect of getting to the basis of its
object to core that is being insofar as
being then the intellect will not be
able to go beyond its proper capacity by
seeking recourse in revelations
proximity without all at once leaving
philosophy's domain to enter that of
theology for philosophy to seek aid from
revelation so as to go beyond what it
can do by itself and on the other hand
to introduce nothing that would be
formally foreign to the rational order
these are certainly two demands that
irremediably exclude each other
the same ambiguities are
cut uncovered again in father certian's
recent article in v antelectual
the thinker who adheres to catholic
doctrine quote tries normally to
disengage the philosophy latent in dogma
and in this he actually does
philosophy's work fitting his rational
philosophy there if he has one and if
this philosophy is capable of
philosophically examining to the extent
that it can dogma itself insofar as
dogma in one way or another interests or
conditions philosophy's own object
the thinker thereby produces for himself
one thought and not two which would be
an inhuman and bifurcated life
if this is not precisely speculative
theology's task what could its object be
and further on
that is by a purely rational method but
receiving dogma under the rubrics of
fact just as much as experience we will
speculate by taking account of the
entire datum without confusion of method
or principles or object with theology
but still reconnecting philosophy with a
total wisdom
what does speculative theology do if
it's not to quote receive dogmas under
the rubric of facts just as much as
experience
what does it do if not speculate by
taking account of the entire datum and
reconnect philosophy of the total wisdom
but then what does this passage signify
without confusion of method of
principles or of object with theology
some have wanted to justify the notion
of christian philosophy by history
history encounters a certain number of
doctrines that present themselves as
christian philosophies mr foret said at
juvensi
but the question is one of knowing what
this expression conceals and whether it
is opportune to restore its usage
one could summarize the historical
evolution of christian thought by saying
that it is the insensible passage of a
confused and chaotic unity to a distinct
and organ organic unity i have recently
shown by following numerous numerous
historians that augustinianism the
augustinian wisdom the christian
philosophy of saint augustine is in some
a christian vision of the world that
constitutes an attempt at a synthesis of
all human natural and supernatural
knowledge this is a superior theology
a theology of the broad sense defined
above
actually there's there's a nice uh
footnote here it is even more than a
theology that is a speculation of felt
and shouting it is before everything
else a doctrine of life a rule of life
capable of assuring to man is beatitude
this idea is insinuated in different
places in the articles i have just noted
particularly
at 124 125 and 230 but mr monsieur
wanted with reason that more light be
shed on it for it is this point of view
that highly justifies the mistrust
augustine professes for pagan
philosophers incapable of resolving the
enigma of human destiny and conducting
man to his true end
all right
back to fond steinberg
but this systematization
is not systematically organized the
problems are not set out in a series
there methods are barely distinguished
the preoccupation of scientific
scientific technique are absent in it
the scientific organization of knowledge
was the progressive work of centuries an
important part goes back to albert the
great and his disciple thomas aquinas in
this work of the ages
but the catholic philosophers and
theologians today
are still far from having exhausted the
fertility of the principles set out by
these great doctors and partially
applied by them
medieval philosophy has nearly always
suffered from its too close contact with
theology it disengaged itself only with
great trouble from this tutelage and
when this had taken place the reaction
was often excessive this was the case
for the masters of paris who inaugurated
in the 13th century a strictly
philosophical movement in the faculty of
arts
their impatient effort blinded by an
inconsiderable enthusiasm inconsiderate
enthusiasm for aristotle collided with
ecclesiastical teaching sometimes even
with faith certain data
and they had trouble recognizing a
superior truth's control over the
conclusions of philosophical research
but the opposed excess is even much more
frequent today still
many catholic philosophers deformed by
theology do not succeed in imposing on
themselves a strictly philosophical
method
and then again theologians poorly
informed about the precise signification
of philosophical conclusions
make unfortunate use of them in their
interpretation of the revealed datum we
suffer much more from the confusion of
philosophy and theology than from their
isolation quite often our philosophy is
already only too christian in the sense
that it integrates elements borrowed
from revelation or from theology without
assimilating them according to the
demands of its rational methods
from now on we must guard against
favoring by the use of an inexact
expression a tendency against which to
the contrary it is important to react
the conclusion of this note will be
brief there are christian philosophers
because some christians can give
themselves over to philosophical
research and because their christianity
disposes them to give themselves over
worth perspicuity and with prudence with
serenity it helps them with working out
a true philosophy
to the degree that it is true a
philosophy is necessarily compatible
with christianity open to christianity
utilizable by christianity and by
theology its content will be able to
partially coincide with that of
revelation
but a philosophy will never be christian
in the formal and rigorous sense
one can doubtless speak of christian
philosophers in a purely material sense
to designate philosophies that have been
worked out by christian thinkers
but since the facts demonstrate the
latent danger of this usage it would be
better to avoid using an expression that
far from illuminating anything
is a source of confusions and
equivocations
so
that is fernand von steinbergens one of
his many contributions to the debates
but the only one that is translated here
in this work
reason fulfilled by revelation the 1930s
christian philosophy debates in france
we've got some questions and comments
here i am going to say something as i've
been
reading this today
i
am thinking about the things that that
haven't been translated you know for
example the account of the
second day of studies that
fond steinberg is summarizing which is
about a hundred page document or so i
have a copy i actually bought a copy of
it years and years ago as well as a copy
of the first day of studies
and that strikes me if i ever do start
translating this stuff again that's
that's one of the documents that
really really needs to be translated and
you know fond steinberg and wrote some
other stuff as well that should be
translated so did certian so did blondel
um
you know if i get enough time on my
hands it's it's a task that i would
relish returning to because translating
is actually quite enjoyable you know you
you don't actually have to have any
original thoughts of your own
um you basically get to
see how you can take somebody else's
interesting and original thoughts and
you know move them from french in this
case into english or latin into english
in the case of anselm or you know greek
in the case of
whoever else we might pick or german or
whatever right so
um and you know as i re-read this
i'm glad that i put von steinberg in
here because he's an opponent of
christian philosophy from the
neo-scholastic position
but he's a thoughtful sophisticated
opponent he's raising a lot of good
points that have to be
addressed all right so let me
uh
mark
is late
uh glad you could be here mark
adam just wanted to say hi thank you for
the easy explanation your videos are
you're very welcome now here we get to
some more substantive things
that distinction between christian
philosophy and a philosophy of
christianity has never struck me before
that's something i'm gonna have to go
think about
yeah i mean and i think it's two
different
ways of looking at the
the engagement between philosophy and
christianity you know when we're doing
philosophy of religion so von
steinbergen's proposal here is we've got
philosophy of religion and that's going
to be a very broad inquiry
um it's not just going to be the you
know proofs for god's existence or
discussions about religious language or
whatever trendy topic is is on the
horizon for
uh people working in that field it's
going to be a very vast and
comprehensive sort of thing
trying to you know make sense out of
religion and there there have been some
awesome awesome contributions to this
throughout the 19th and 20th century i
mean hegel has his own lectures on the
philosophy of religion which you know
are pretty cool there's this guy john
airing
spelled like like herring you know
who is a phenomenologist of of religion
you know
there's lots and lots of really great
stuff out there i mean think about
william james the varieties of religious
experiences looking at one aspect of
that actually a lot of the gifford
lectures because the gifford lectures
are supposed to be
oriented towards religion many people
don't actually do them that way but you
know that was part of the intent
and so yeah you know then you look at
christianity
as one big religion among others right
so there would also be like say a
philosophy of hinduism as opposed to
hindu philosophy right or a philosophy
of
buddhism as opposed to you know buddhist
scholastic you know metaphysics carried
out in therabata or mahayana schools
um i i kind of think this is you know
this is a viable project i i i would say
that you know somebody who does carry
something like that out is the great
phenomenologist uh mark schaeler you
know he is doing some of that darth
vader asks what is phenomenology of
religion uh looking at religion from
phenomenological perspectives you know
uh what is phenomenology right there's a
whole vast movement what is
phenomenology as applied to say sports
phenomenology of sports what is
phenomenology is applied to the vast
field of religion phenomenology of
religion you know
so
um yeah so it's it's kind of an
interesting thing ricky says i've always
wondered this doesn't christianity
borrow from philosophy um i don't think
you can say christianity per se borrows
from philosophy although
um insofar as some of the key texts you
know for most christians pre-protestant
are philosophical
um it certainly has philosophy
incorporated into it think of the book
of the wisdom of solomon in which wisdom
is personified and there's lots of uh
interesting
philosophical discussion being being
raised there think of the uh you know
wisdom of sarak
the book of job is essentially a
philosophical dialogue so there's
already some stuff
there
and then you know christianity emerges
within a
socio-historical context that is already
informed by
greek and roman philosophy as well as
many other things you know think about
rhetoric
augustine was a rhetorician you know he
studied rhetoric
medicine all these other fields that are
kind of interlocking that we often like
to distinguish very far apart from each
other
but in ancient times were not they were
part of the cultural heritage and
christianity is emerging into that
so you will find christian thinkers very
very explicitly engaging
what fond steinberg in here is calling
pagan philosophy
some of the early church fathers
do so
you know quite explicitly think of
justin martyr or clement of alexandria
or tatyan
or
you know tertullian or loctancius these
are all people who know philosophy
and are saying i'm going to accept this
from from these guys usually it's from
the platonus but there's some things
from the stoix or the aristotelians
though the one that they won't accept
anything from
and nobody really liked them was the
epicureans right
so yeah there's there's lots of
incorporation of things
from you can call them borrowings if you
want or you could just you know call
them what they are in corporations and
assimilations and going further with
these these things because that's what
these early christian thinkers
do in fact talk about them as you know
the
platonic tripartite psychology is relied
upon
by um
you know most of the early christian
thinkers because that's kind of the
going psychology of the day you know
where you've got logos tumos and
epithumia
so you'll find you know references to
that
um and you know philosophy also is
enriched by
christianity and that's part of what
these christian philosophy debates are
are pointing out in large respect
um
jambus thanks for your videos i'm going
to keep reading and watching your videos
to understand as much philosophy as i
can well that that's great there are
some very big gaps in coverage i know it
may not look at that like that from the
outside but i'm like hyper conscious of
how many
texts and thinkers i haven't actually
covered even like some of the people
that i do a lot of work on like
aristotle i've covered the whole of the
nick of mccain ethics
but other than that it's just you know
one class session on on the topics and
some uh metaphysics book one and
politics book one you know there's an
awful lot even if i just wanted to do
aristotle that i would need to get to
as well
um
so you know not to mention other figures
that i haven't i haven't addressed at
all like i don't have a single video on
leibniz for example you know
all right uh
darth vader are christian theology and
christian philosophy different from one
another depends on who you ask right
some people make very very rigid
distinctions between them
i kind of think there's no such thing as
theology or philosophy as just like one
big block that's that's dealing with
things very very abstractly but then
again
i am somebody who you know reads a lot
of thinkers and can see just how
different what we call philosophy is in
all these different
thinkers and theology you know sometimes
uh depends on who you're asking right um
some some stuff that some people would
call theology really is philosophy and
vice versa so we we always have to
specify a little bit and that was one of
the problems with with a number of the
people
writing in this debate you know
if if you're thinking in very abstract
terms and you're saying well there's a
division here between philosophy on this
side and theology on this side
one of the problems that you have to
deal with is is that a philosophical or
a theological distinction which side are
you on when you're actually making this
dividing line right and we have better
models for the interpenetration
of
not just philosophy and theology but
also
the you know
things that we call the sciences which
are kind of a grab bag you know
including the social sciences natural
sciences medicine mathematics you know
all of which are kind of different from
each other and doing different things um
the the fine arts the other humanities
history you know it's it's often quite
difficult to well it's not difficult to
say where the dividing line is it's
difficult to be able to justify that
dividing line
in the face of other people who say that
seems rather
arbitrary so
oh wow it's all we got about 10 minutes
left
time is going quick i guess that's what
happens when you pick a big article
well while i'm seeing if anybody else
has anything
else they want to ask or say i'll say we
have two more sessions
the next two sessions are both things
coming from the review neo scholastic to
philosophy as as was this one
the uh one coming up next week will be
maurice blondell for an integral
philosophy in which he's responding a
bit to von steinbergen and further
elaborating his own point of view
and you know we've already had
three contributions by blondel in in
this work
so that'll be the fourth one and then we
have something that some people have
been looking forward to a
phenomenological approach to this by
leon noel who you noticed von
steinbergen was talking about as
monsignor noel right
and that is called the notion of
christian philosophy and he's going to
be
using a husserlian perspective to say
that there really isn't any such
thing rigorously speaking as christian
philosophy so he's going to be
um
he's going to be connecting with that
darth vader how does christian
philosophy approach or engage with the
gnostic thought there's no such thing as
the gnostic thought there's only gnostic
thoughts right
um gnosticism is there is no internal
it consistency to gnosticism
the one thing that one gnostic hated
more than the orthodox was another
gnostic so you know we have valencians
gnosticism and we have manichaeism and
we have this and this and this but there
is no overall
gnostic thought there's only a bunch of
different things that we lump together
under one
big loose loose umbrella
and um i mean how did christian
philosophy approach or engage with
nausica thought rita augustine's
confessions augustine was for a while a
manichaean
and you know he's one of the really
important christian philosophers so
there isn't an awful lot of engagement
of that in the middle ages other than
you know polemics against catherism
which is a revival of gnosticism mostly
in the south of france
um
but it's not really that connected with
that mark what are your thoughts on
mystical theology do you
engage in any aesthesis like meditation
well mystical theology is one of those
things that again can mean a million
different things because the word
mystical
is is a very equivocal term some people
use it for like dabbling with crystals
and you know burning uh incense
and uh doing all sorts of new agey stuff
other people you know think about the
great mystery
religions most of which we don't
actually know that much about
uh and then there's you know like uh
mysticism in in terms of authors who are
viewed as being mystics
i mean one of the problems is if
anything is genuinely mystical it should
be difficult to articulate right
um meditation can be done
in ways that are connected with
mysticism meditation can also be done in
ways that have zero connection with that
you know mindfulness meditation which is
a kind of preparatory thing to
visualization
um that can be very very straightforward
and doesn't have to be connected with
with mysticism at all um
so
you know do i engage in in uh esthesis
like like meditation no not much i've
done so in the past with like you know
reading um and contemplation but i don't
do too much of that these days
uh darth vader what are your thoughts on
negative theology or negative theology i
i'm not big on on negative theology
myself i think it you know in part
because of the time that i came up in
graduate school everybody was like oh
this is so cool it became a fad
and then you know a lot of people fell
away from it because you you probably
can't just do negative theology you need
some some stuff that's actually
providing a positive content there
um
danny does blondel ever address the fall
of the devil or the fall of man if so
how do you think he would address those
questions he doesn't worry about the
fall of the devil he yeah he talks
plenty about the fallen state of human
beings um
and that comes up actually in his the
problem to the philosophy kataleek right
we we exist in a
uh
we don't exist in a state of pure nature
we exist in a state of damaged nature
so but that that text isn't translated
unfortunately
uh once they were named me i wasn't what
do you think about material being linked
to mind how our mind and matter
indistinguishable or
philosophy is continually evolving yeah
i mean none of that really has to do
with the christian philosophy debate
stuff so i'm gonna punt on that
um mark says is chris in christianity i
mean like what somebody like
pseudo-dianisos does okay so
pseudo-neonisos there we have somebody
who you can call a mystic
and it's christian neoplatonism and it's
very well worked out and there's a lot
of of content there so yeah that's
that's uh cool stuff myself i'm not
attracted to mysticism any more than i
am to negative theology
so you know i leave that to other people
but i tend to be kind of pluralistic
when it comes to approaches
michael aren't augustine and aquinas
considered to be christian philosophers
or are they theologians both
depends on how you look at them right uh
this is something we just talked about
you've got to be able to say what
philosophy and theology are and where
the borderline between them lies and do
so in a plausible manner if you want to
make that distinction well
so
you know
uh massac i i'm currently reading oxyo
1893 do you think his critique stood the
test of time
um his critique of science yeah i think
it's pretty good i mean i i also think
that
um you know mcintyre's criticism of
social science and after virtue is
pretty dead on
you know um
criticizing science is like shooting
fish in a barrel you know um
scientists are often very very
naive about their own work and you know
proponents of i love science are usually
even more naive
and often don't understand the history
of their own disciplines so
yeah it's pretty easy to raise uh uh
complaints against totalizing scientism
um and that but that's not all that
blondel is doing in oxian 1893. you know
there's a lot more
going on there
darth vader what are your thoughts on
saint paul i'm not a big fan of paul you
know um
i think that the other letters in in the
uh new testament are just as important
as as those of paul
um
they're all you know
interesting documents i don't buy the
silly
you know i mean here's here's the thing
when it comes to any sort of like
sweeping christianity is all about this
or you know here's the whole story and
you got it compressed in one sentence
like people are like oh jesus was a nice
guy and then paul made him mean i think
that's complete [ __ ] um you know but
it's it's clear that that paul has his
well-developed take i mean some people
sometimes call it the fifth gospel
putting his letters together some people
also call the psalms the fifth gospel by
the way including you know thomas
aquinas and his commentary on the psalms
um so
there's there's you know interesting
insights that are gotten i think people
who take paul
and you know particularly certain ideas
and then run with them often wind up in
a lot of problems this is where we get
things like the rapture
or you know um
you know weird weird doctrines that are
are not really important and uh that
don't have much to do with with actual
you know faith and morals
paul is kind of rich in things that can
be taken wildly out of context and then
turned into their own shtick but is that
paul's fault you know
he he doesn't know who uh who's going to
be reading him and and misinterpreting
him you know uh
20 centuries from from the time that he
well that would be later on 19 and a
half centuries from the time that he's
writing i mean
any more than aristotle would know that
we're you know taking his texts and
doing different things with them today
right
um
massack has
something here do you think philosophers
who critique science from a metaphysical
point of view like heidegger are better
than philosophers who created science
based on assumed axioms like shaler and
sociology i think you've misread mock
shaler
or you relied on somebody else's take on
him shaler has just as much metaphysical
depth as heidegger does
so you know despite the fact that he was
actually willing to do a philosophical
sociology which heidegger was not that
doesn't mean that all he's doing is
sociology um i i think shaler's a better
philosopher than than um heidegger quite
frankly you know and it's it's too bad
he died so young
but
there you have it
uh
absalom i prayed to god a couple weeks
ago to either destroy my bullies or turn
them to christians this is the hardcore
essence of being a christian i would say
that has nothing to do with being a
christian
i mean
praying to god to destroy your bullies
or turn them into christians
that's kind of a you know
a strange thing to be to be asking
uh the divine being that's you know got
a lot of different things going on
um
i would i would focus on figuring out
how you're gonna deal with these bullies
you know
and it's definitely not at the essence
of being christian you know if
think about the sermon on the mount what
are you supposed to do for your enemies
there
you are supposed to pray for them are
you supposed to pray that they get
destroyed or that they become christians
i don't know that that's exactly what
pray for your enemies means
so
all right uh
i'm gonna have to get going in just a
minute here
uh darth vader or husserl and heidegger
deeply influenced by christianity and
their philosophical thought it would be
weird for husserl who was jewish to be
uh influenced he's not even influenced
by his judaism
and heidegger you know
not not really that much i mean
heidegger thinks christianity is a
mistake right
um spinoza some scholars think the
christ hymn in philippians 2 is an early
christian creed do you have any thoughts
on it i don't have a single thought on
it you know
once they were named do you think jung's
answer to job sheds new light on the
importance of the resurrection of christ
no
but then again i you know i haven't read
jung's answer to job but i'm not a big
young person
finally absalom but many puritans had
this mindset
yeah i would i would say have you read a
lot of puritan literature and and found
that to be the case because if you're
relying on glosses of the puritans you
might not actually be that accurate um
when it comes to like characterizing
them i would worry less about what
puritans who are always a tiny minority
were doing and i don't know maybe maybe
go back to some classic christian
authors and see what they have to say
you know
all right so i'm going to bring this to
a close we're already like a minute over
time got a little bit off topic here
with all sorts of things um
two more readings coming up from reason
fulfilled by revelation
and i will see some of you
there all right i'll see you later